Je vais vous amener en voyage très rapidement.
Pour expliquer mon souhait, je vais devoir vous emmener quelque part
où beaucoup de gens ne sont pas allés, et ça partout dans le monde.
Lorsque j'avais environ 24 ans, Kate Store et moi-même lancions une organisation
pour impliquer les architectes et concepteurs dans le travail humanitaire.
Pas seulement pour répondre aux catastrophes naturelles,
mais pour les impliquer dans des problèmes systémiques.
Nous pensions que lorsque les ressources et l'expérience sont rares,
la conception durable, innovante peut réellement faire la différence dans la vie des gens.
Et c'est ainsi que tout commença – J'ai commencé ma vie en tant qu'architecte, ou par une formation d'architecte,
et j'ai toujours été intéressé par la conception socialement responsable,
et comment on peut réellement avoir un impact.
Mais quand je suis allé à l'école d'architecture,
il m'a semblé que j'étais le mouton noir de la famille.
Beaucoup d'architectes semblent penser que lorsque vous concevez,
vous concevez un bijou, et c'est un bijou que vous essayer d'obtenir maladivement.
Alors que je sentais que quand vous concevez,
soit vous améliorez, soit vous portez préjudice
à la communauté pour laquelle vous concevez.
Donc vous ne faites pas un bâtiment juste pour les résidents
ou pour les personnes qui vont l'utiliser,
mais pour la communauté dans sa globalité.
Et en 1999, nous avons commencé à répondre au problème de la crise du logement
pour le retour des réfugiés au Kosovo
et je ne savais pas ce que j'étais en train de faire, comme je l'ai dit, dans ma vingtaine,
et je suis, je suis de la génération internet, donc j'ai lancé un site web.
Nous y avons fait un appel d'offres, et à ma grande surprise en quelques mois
nous avons eu des centaines de visites du monde entier.
Cela a mené à un certain nombre de prototypes en cours de construction
permettant d'expérimenter quelques idées.
Deux années plus tard, nous avons lancé un projet
pour developper des cliniques de santé mobiles en Afrique sub-saharienne,
en réponse à la pandémie VIH/SIDA.
Cela – cela a mené à 550 entrées venant de 53 pays.
Nous avons aussi des concepteurs venant des quatre coins du monde qui ont participé.
Et nous avons ensuite exposé ces travaux.
2004 était le point de basculement pour nous.
Nous avons commencé à répondre aux catastrophes naturelles
et nous nous sommes impliqués en Iran et à Bam,
tout en poursuivant nos travaux en Afrique.
Lorsqu'ils travaillent à l'intérieur des États-Unis,
la plupart des gens voient le visage d'un étranger lorsqu'ils pensent à la pauvreté,
mais allez vivre – je vis à Bozeman, dans le Montana –
allez dans les plaines au nord des réserves indiennes,
ou allez dans l'Alabama ou le Mississippi
avant Katrina, et j'aurais pu vous montrer des endroits
où les conditions sont bien pires que dans beaucoup des pays en voie de développement dans lesquels je suis allé.
Donc nous nous sommes impliqués et avons travaillé dans des villes à l'intérieur du pays et ailleurs.
Et je vais aussi entrer dans plusieurs projets supplémentaires.
En 2005, Mère Nature nous a botté les fesses.
Je pense qu'on peut décemment dire que 2005 était une année atroce
lorsque l'on parle de catastrophes naturelles.
Et grâce à internet,
grâce aux connections aux blogs et autres,
quelques heures après le tsunami, littéralement, nous étions déjà en train de réunir des fonds,
de nous impliquer, en travaillant avec des gens sur le terrain.
Nous avons commencé avec une paire de portables durant les deux premiers jours,
j'avais 4000 emails venant de personnes qui avaient besoin d'aide.
Donc nous avons commencé à nous impliquer dans des projets là-bas,
et je vais vous parler de quelques autres.
Ensuite, bien sûr, cette année nous avons réagi suite à Katrina,
tout en continuant nos travaux de reconstruction.
Ceci est une rapide vue d'ensemble.
En 2004, je ne pouvais vraiment pas gérer
le nombre de personnes qui avaient besoin d'aide,
ou le nombre de demandes que je recevais.
Tout arrivait sur mon portable ou mon téléphone.
Donc nous avons décidé d'adopter un –
fondamentalement un modèle de commerce en source libre,
afin que chacun, n'importe où dans le monde, puisse lancer une section locale,
et s'impliquer dans les problèmes locaux.
Parce que je crois qu'il n'y a rien comme Utopia.
Tous les problèmes sont locaux. Toutes les solutions sont locales.
Donc, cela signifie, vous le savez,
que quelqu'un basé dans le Mississippi,
en sait plus sur le Mississippi que moi. Donc, ce qu'il s'est passé,
c'est que nous avons utilisé MeetUp et tous ces autres genres d'outils internet,
et avons fini par avoir 40 sections locales lancées,
des milliers d'architectes dans 104 pays.
Donc, la puce – désolé, je ne porte jamais de veste,
donc je savais que j'allais enlever celle-là.
OK, parce que je vais aller très vite.
Durant les sept dernières années, il ne s'agissait pas seulement de quelque chose à but non lucratif.
Cela m'a montré qu'il y a un mouvement de base
de la part de concepteurs socialement responsables
qui pensent réellement que ce monde est devenu beaucoup plus petit,
et que nous avons l'opportunité – non pas la responsabilité,
mais l'opportunité – de réellement s'impliquer pour le changement.
(Rires)
J'ajoute ça à mon temps.
Ce que vous ne savez donc pas est que,
nous avons ces milliers de concepteurs travaillant autour du monde,
connectés simplement via un site internet, et nous avons une équipe de trois personnes.
Comme personne ne nous a dit que nous ne pouvions pas le faire,
nous l'avons fait. Et il y a donc quelque chose à dire à propos de la naïveté.
Sept ans plus tard, nous nous sommes développés au point d'avoir soutien,
instigation et exécution. Nous soutenons une bonne conception,
pas seulement au travers d'ateliers étudiants, de conférences et de forums publics
des articles, nous avons un livre sur le travail humanitaire,
mais nous travaillons aussi à diminuer l'impact des catastrophes naturelles en traitant avec la politique publique.
On peut parler de FEMA, mais c'est un autre sujet.
L'instigation, le développement des idées avec les communautés
et les organisations non-gouvernementales pour lancer des compétitions de conception open-source.
Se référer et chercher la correspondance aux souhaits des communautés
et ensuite exécuter – en fait aller là-bas et faire le travail,
parce que lorsque vous inventez, ce n'est pas réel tant que ce n'est pas construit.
Ce qui est donc réellement important est que si nous concevons
et nous essayons de créer le changement, nous devons construire ce changement.
Voici donc un certain nombre de projets sélectionnés.
Le Kosovo. Voici le Kosovo en 1999. Nous avons lancé une compétition ouverte de conception,
comme je l'ai dit. Cela a conduit à une grande quantité d'idées,
et ce n'était pas à propos d'un abri d'urgence, mais d'un abri de transition
qui durerait entre 5 et 10 ans,
et qui serait placé à côté du terrain où son habitant vivait,
Et ce afin qu'ils puissent reconstruire leur propre maison.
Cela n'imposait pas une architecture dans une communauté,
cela leur donnait les outils et,
l'espace leur permettant
de reconstruire et replanter comme ils le voulaient.
Nous en avons qui vont du sublime au ridicule, mais ils fonctionnaient.
Ceci est une maison de chanvre gonflable. Ça a été construit ; ça fonctionne.
Ceci est un container maritime. Il a été construit et est opérationnel.
Et une grande variété d'idées
qui ne touchent pas uniquement à la construction architecturale,
mais aussi aux problèmes de gouvernance
et à l'idée de créer des communautés à travers des réseaux complexes.
Donc nous n'avons pas engagé que des concepteurs, mais aussi,
vous savez, une grande variété de professionnels dans divers domaines technologiques.
Nous avons utilisé les gravas de maisons détruites pour en créer de nouvelles.
Nous avons utilisé des constructions à base de bottes de paille afin de créer des murs qui conservent la chaleur.
Puis quelque chose de remarquable arriva en 1999.
Nous sommes allés en Afrique, à l'origine pour se renseigner sur la crise du logement.
En trois jours, nous avons réalisé que le problème n'était pas le logement;
c'était la pandémie grandissante de HIV/SIDA.
Et ce n'étaient pas des docteurs qui nous le disaient ;
c'étaient en fait les villageois avec lesquels nous étions.
Et nous avons donc eu cette brillante idée : au lieu d'obliger les gens
à marcher 10, 15 kilomètres pour voir des docteurs, nous amènerions les docteurs auprès des gens.
Nous avons donc commencé à impliquer la communauté médicale.
Et je pensais, vous savez, nous pensions que nous étions réellement brillants –
nous avions eu cette idée géniale, des cliniques de santé mobile –
largement distribuées à travers l'Afrique sub-saharienne.
Et la communauté, la communauté médicale, nous a dit,
« Nous avons dit ça pendant les dix dernières années. Nous savons cela.
Nous ne savons juste pas comment le montrer. »
Nous avions donc pris un besoin préexistant et montré des solutions.
Et de nouveau nous avons eu une grande variété d'idées qui nous sont parvenues.
Celle-ci que j'affectionne tout particulièrement,
parce que cette idée d'architecture n'est pas juste une solution,
mais permet d'augmenter la prise de conscience.
C'est une clinique kenaf. Vous prenez une graine et vous la faites pousser dans une parcelle de terre,
et il grandit de 4,2 mètres en un mois.
Et durant la quatrième semaine, les docteurs viennent et tondent une zone,
mettent une structure extensible au sommet
et quand les docteurs ont fini de traiter
et de voir les patients et les villageois,
vous coupez la clinique et vous la mangez. C'est Mangez Votre Propre Clinique.
(Rires)
Cela interagit avec le fait que si vous avez le SIDA,
vous avez aussi besoin de certains taux nutritionnels,
et l'idée que le concept même de nutrition est aussi important
que le fait d'avoir des anti-rétrovirus là bas.
Donc vous voyez, c'est une solution sérieuse.
J'aime celle-ci. Cette idée n'est pas juste une clinique, c'est un centre communautaire.
Cela concerne l'ouverture de routes de commerce
et la création de moteurs économiques dans la communauté,
ce pourrait donc être un projet autofinancé.
Chacun de ces projets est durable.
Ce n'est pas parce que je suis un amoureux des arbres.
C'est parce que lorsque vous vivez avec quatre dollars par jour,
vous vivez en survivant et vous devez être viable.
Vous devez savoir d'où vient votre énergie.
Vous devez savoir d'où viennent vos ressources.
Vous devez garder un entretien faible.
Il s'agit donc d'obtenir un moteur économique,
et ensuite à la nuit tombée ça se tranforme en cinéma.
Donc ce n'est pas une clinique pour le SIDA, c'est un centre communautaire.
Donc vous pouvez voir ces idées. Et ces idées ce sont développées en prototypes,
qui ont été finalement construites. Et actuellement,
il y a des cliniques qui roulent au Nigéria et au Kenya.
À partir de là nous avons aussi développé Siyathemba, qui était un projet –
la communauté est venue à nous et nous a dit
que le problème est que les filles n'ont pas d'éducation.
Et nous travaillons dans une zone
où 50 % des jeunes femmes entre 16 et 24 ans
sont atteintes du VIH/SIDA
Et ce n'est pas parce qu'elles ont les mœurs légères,
c'est parce qu'elles ne savent pas.
Nous avons donc décidé de nous pencher sur l'idée du sport et de créer un centre sportif de la jeunesse
doublé d'un centre d'assistance pour le VIH/SIDA,
et les entraineurs des équipes féminines étaient aussi entrainés en tant que docteurs.
Afin que tout doucement
se développe une forme de confiance envers le domaine de la santé.
Nous avons donc choisi neuf finalistes
et ces neufs finalistes étaient distribués à travers la région entière,
afin que la communauté choisisse leur conception.
Ils disaient, c'est notre conception,
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement d'engager la communauté,
il s'agit de rendre la communauté plus puissante
et d'en faire une part du processus de reconstruction.
Et voici donc la conception gagnante, et ensuite bien sûr,
nous avons été là-bas et avons travaillé avec la communauté et les clients.
Voici le concepteur. Il est là-bas à travailler
avec la toute première équipe féminine de football à Kwa-Zulu Natal, Siyathemba,
et ils vous le diront mieux que moi.
Vidéo : Et bien, mon nom est Sisi parce que je travaille au centre africain.
Je suis consultante et je suis également une joueuse nationale de football
pour l'équipe d'Afrique de Sud, les Bafana Bafana,
et je joue également dans le championnat Vodacom avec l'équipe baptisée Tembisa,
qui est maintenant devenue Siyathemba.
C'est notre terrain à domicile.
Cameron Sinclair: Je vais vous montrer ça plus tard car je n'ai plus beaucoup de temps.
Je peux voir Chris qui me regarde du coin de l'œil.
C'était une connexion,
juste une rencontre avec quelqu'un qui voulait développer
le premier centre de télémédecine africain, en Tanzanie
Et nous nous sommes rencontrés il y a deux mois, littéralement. Nous avons déjà developpé une conception
et l'équipe est là-bas, travaillant en partenariat avec elle.
Cela correspondait, grâce à deux membres de TED:
Chreyl Heller et Andrew Zolli,
qui m'ont mis en relation avec cette incroyable femme africaine.
Nous avons commencé la construction en juin et ce sera ouvert par TEDGlobal.
Donc si vous venez à TEDGlobal, vous pourrez vérifier.
Mais ce pour quoi nous sommes les plus connus est probablement pour réagir après les catastrophes naturelles et le développement,
et nous nous sommes impliqués dans de nombreux problèmes
comme le tsunami et aussi des choses comme l'ouragan Katrina.
Ceci est un abri à 370 dollars qui peut facilement être assemblé.
Ceci est une communauté de concepteurs.
Un centre communautaire conçu par une communauté.
Et ce que cela signifie est que nous vivons et travaillons bel et bien avec la communauté,
et qu'ils sont une partie du processus de conception.
Les enfants s'investissent pour décider
où devrait se situer le centre communautaire, et finalement,
la communauté, au travers de l'acquisition de compétences
finit en réalité par construire le bâtiment avec nous.
Voici une autre école.
Voici ce que les Nations Unies ont donné à ces gars pour six mois – douze bâches en plastique.
C'était en aout. Il s'agissait des pièces de rechange,
et elles sont supposées tenir deux ans.
Lorsque la pluie tombe, vous ne pouvez rien entendre,
et en été il fait environ 60°C à l'intérieur.
Donc nous avons dit, si la pluie tombe, récupérons de l'eau fraiche.
Donc tous ceux de notre école ont un système de récupération d'eau de pluie, à très bas prix.
Une classe, trois salles de cours et un système de récupération d'eau reviennent à 5000 dollars.
Ceci a été réuni grâce à des ventes de chocolat chaud à Atlanta.
C'est construit par les parents des enfants.
Les enfants sont là-bas sur le terrain, construisant les bâtiments.
Et ça a ouvert il y a de ça deux semaines,
et 600 enfants utilisent ces écoles aujourd'hui.
(Applaudissements)
Une catastrophe naturelle frappe une maison.
Nous avons vu ces histoires horribles sur CNN et Fox et tout ça,
mais on ne voit pas les histoires positives.
Voici une communauté qui s'est rassemblé et a dit : nous n'attendrons pas.
Ils ont formé une association, une association de divers joueurs
pour élaborer East Biloxi,
et comprendre qui était impliqué.
Nous avons eu 1500 volontaires reconstruisant, rendant les maisons de nouveau habitables.
Comprenant ce que sont les consignes de la FEMA,
et n'attendant pas qu'ils nous dictent comment on devrait reconstruire.
Travaillant avec les résidents, les sortant de leurs maisons,
pour qu'ils n'attrapent pas de maladies. Voici comment ils nettoient leur propre maison.
La conception de logements. Cette maison va partir, dans deux semaines.
C'est une maison de nouveau habitable, nettoyée en quatre jours.
C'est une buanderie pour une femme utilisant un déambulateur.
Elle a 70 ans. Voici ce que la FEMA lui a donné.
600 dollars, c'est arrivé il y a deux jours.
Nous avons assemblé très rapidement une buanderie.
C'est construit, ça fonctionne et elle a démarré son affaire aujourd'hui même,
dans laquelle elle lave les vêtements d'autres personnes.
Voici Shandra et les Calhouns. ils sont photographes
qui ont documenté le Lower Ninth durant les 40 dernières années.
C'était leur maison et voici les photographies qu'ils ont prises.
Nous avons aidé, travaillant avec eux pour créer un nouveau bâtiment.
Des projets que nous avons réalisés. Des projets auxquels nous avons participé, que nous avons supporté.
Pourquoi les agences d'aide ne font pas ça ? Voici une tente des Nations Unies.
Voici la nouvelle tente des Nations Unies, qui vient d'être présentée.
Rapide à assembler. Elle a un rabat, c'est ça l'invention.
Cela a pris 20 ans pour concevoir ça et le mettre en place sur le terrain.
J'avais 12 ans. Il y a un problème ici.
Heureusement, nous ne sommes pas seuls.
Il y a des milliers et des milliers et des milliers
et des milliers d'architectes, de concepteurs et d'inventeurs
autour du monde qui s'investissent dans le travail humanitaire.
D'autres maisons de chaume – c'est un thème au Japon apparemment.
Je ne suis pas certain de ce qu'ils fument.
C'est une attache fixable conçue par quelqu'un qui a dit, tout ce dont vous avez besoin c'est d'une certaine façon
d'attacher des structures en membrane à des poutres physiques de support.
Ce gars qui concevait pour la NASA – conçoit maintenant des logements.
Je vais passer sur cette partie très vite,
parce que je sais que je n'ai que quelques minutes.
Ceci a donc été fait durant les deux dernières années.
Je vous ai montré quelque chose qui a demandé vingt ans pour être mis en place.
Et voici juste une sélection de choses qui sont arrivées –
qui ont été construites durant les deux dernières années.
Du Brésil à l'Inde,
au Mexique,
en Alabama,
en Chine,
en Israël,
en Palestine,
au Vietnam.
L'âge moyen d'un concepteur
qui s'implique dans ce projet est de 32 ans – c'est mon âge. Donc c'est jeune –
Je dois juste arrêter là, car Arup est dans la pièce
et ce sont les toilettes les mieux conçues au monde.
Si vous jamais un jour vous allez en Inde, utilisez ces toilettes.
(Rires)
Chris Luebkeman vous dira pourquoi.
je suis certain que c'est la façon dont il voulait passer la fête, mais –
mais le futur ne sera pas les cités de gratte-ciel comme New York,
mais voilà. Lorsque vous regardez ceci vous voyez une crise.
Ce que je vois c'est de nombreux, nombreux inventeurs.
Un milliard de personnes vivent dans une pauvreté abjecte.
Nous entendons parler d'eux tout le temps.
Quatre milliards vivent dans une économie croissante mais fragile.
Une personne sur sept vit dans des conditions précaires.
Si nous ne faisons rien pour la crise des logements qui est sur le point d'arriver,
dans vingt ans, une personne sur trois vivra dans des conditions précaires
ou dans un camp de réfugiés. Regardez à votre gauche, regardez à votre droite : un de vous y sera.
Comment élever le niveau de vie de cinq milliards de personnes?
Avec dix millions de solutions.
Mon souhait est donc de développer une communauté qui adopte
une conception innovante et durable
afin d'améliorer les conditions de vie de chacun.
CA : Attendez une seconde. Attendez une seconde. C'est votre souhait?
C'est mon souhait.
C'est son souhait!
(Applaudissements)
Nous avons lancé Architecture for Humanity avec 700 dollars et un site internet.
Donc Chris a en quelque sorte décidé de me donner 100 000 dollars.
Alors pourquoi autant de gens ?
L'architecture open-source est la voie à suivre.
Vous avez une communauté de participants variés –
et nous ne parlons pas seulement d'inventeurs et de concepteurs,
mais nous parlons du modèle de financement.
Mon rôle n'est pas celui de concepteur,
c'est celui de lien entre le monde de la conception et celui de l'humanitaire.
Et ce dont nous avons besoin c'est quelque chose qui reproduise ce lien dans son ensemble,
parce que je n'ai pas dormi en sept ans.
(Rires)
Deuxièmement, que sera cette chose?
Les concepteurs veulent répondre aux problèmes liés à la crise humanitaire,
mais ils ne veulent pas une quelconque entreprise dans l'Ouest
qui prenne leurs idées et en tire basiquement des profits.
Donc Creative Commons a développé la licence des nations en développement.
Et ce que ça signifie c'est qu'un concepteur peut – le projet Siyathemba que j'ai montré était le
tout premier bâtiment à avoir la license Creative Commons.
Aussitôt que c'est construit, tout le monde en Afrique ou dans n'importe quelle nation en voie de développement
peut prendre les documents de construction et le dupliquer gratuitement.
(Applaudissements)
Alors pourquoi ne pas donner aux concepteurs l'opportunité de faire ça,
tout en protégeant leurs droits, hein ?
Nous voulons avoir une communauté dans laquelle vous pouvez injecter des idées,
et ces idées peuvent être testées lors de tremblements de terre, d'inondations,
ou dans toutes sortes d'environnements austères. La raison importante c'est
que je ne veux pas attendre le prochain Katrina pour savoir si ma maison tiendra.
C'est trop tard. Nous devons le savoir maintenant.
Et donc faire ça globalement.
De plus je veux que tout ça fonctionne de manière multilingue.
Lorsque vous regardez le visage d'un architecte, la plupart des gens voient un homme blanc aux cheveux grisonnants.
Ce n'est pas ce que je vois. Je vois le visage du monde.
Et donc je veux que chacun sur cette planète
puisse faire partie de cette conception et de ce développement.
L'idée d'une compétition basée sur les besoin – Xe prix pour les autres 98 %,
si vous voulez l'appeler comme ça.
Nous voulons aussi chercher des moyens de faire correspondre
et de mettre ensemble des partenaires.
L'idée de fabricants pour l'intégration – des laboratoires fabuleux dans chaque pays.
Lorsque j'ai entendu parler des ordinateurs portables à 100 dollars
qui vont éduquer tous les enfants,
et éduquer tous les concepteurs dans le monde. Mettez en un dans chaque favela,
dans chaque taudis, parce que vous savez quoi ?
L'innovation viendra.
De plus je dois connaitre ça. C'est appelé le saut dans le temps.
Nous parlons de technologies qui progressent par bonds. J'écris en accord avec les changements du monde,
et la chose dont nous avons parlé est,
que j'apprends plus sur le terrain que je n'ai jamais appris ici.
Prenons ces idées, adaptons-les et nous pourrons les utiliser.
Ces idées sont supposées être adaptables,
elles ont le droit d'être – elles devraient avoir le potentiel d'évoluer,
elles devraient être développées par chaque nation dans le monde
et elles sont utiles à chaque nation dans le monde. Qu'est-ce que ça prendra ?
Il devrait y avoir une feuille. Je n'ai pas le temps de lire ça,
parce que je vais me faire sortir de force.
CA : Continuons quelques minutes.
CS : Bien, qu'est-ce que ça prendra ? Vous êtes intelligents les gars.
Donc ça va demander une grande capacité de calcul, parce que je veux que ceci –
je veux concrétiser l'idée que chaque ordinateur partout dans le monde puisse le connecter au système
et soit capable non seulement de participer au développement de toutes ces conceptions,
mais puisse aussi utiliser ces conceptions. J'aimerais également un moyen de revoir les conceptions.
Je veux que chaque ingénieur Arup dans le monde puisse vérifier
et s'assurer que nous sommes en train de faire des choses qui tiennent la route,
parce que ces gars sont les meilleurs dans le monde. Branchez.
Donc vous savez que je veux – et je devrais juste noter
que j'ai deux ordinateurs portables et que l'un d'eux est ici
et contient 3000 conceptions. Si je lâche ce portable que va-t-il arriver ?
Il est donc important d'avoir ces idées testées placées ici,
facilement utilisables, facilement accessibles.
Ma mère m'a dit une fois, il n'y a rien de pire que d'avoir une grande gueule et rien dans le pantalon.
(Rires)
J'en ai marre de parler du fait de changer les choses.
On ne le fait vraiment qu'en agissant.
Nous avons changé les lignes directrices de la FEMA. Nous avons changé la politique publique.
Nous avons changé la réponse internationale – basé sur la construction.
Donc pour moi, c'est important que nous créions une ouverture réelle
pour l'innovation, et ça c'est l'innovation libre.
Penser aux cultures libres – c'est l'innovation libre.
Quelqu'un l'a dit il y a deux-trois ans.
Je donnerai des points à ceux qui la connaissent,
je pense que cet homme était en avance d'environ 25 ans, donc agissons.
Merci
(Applaudissements)